[Musique]
et
alors nous allons parler de conquête
spatiale et du lancement d'un nano
satellites coeur a lieu dans la nuit de
mercredi à jeudi du 13 au 14 janvier
avec philippe quelques bonjour bonjour
vous êtes directeur adjoint du latmos
laboratoire atmosphères observations
spatiales vous est aussi vice-président
de l'université versailles saint quentin
alors cet actuel dit brillante en effet
ce lancement de ce nano satellites qui
est vraiment tout petit et qui va avoir
lieu depuis la californie ça tout à fait
alors pour nous c'est une première
puisque tout a été conçu ici
et imaginez est donc là on va on a mis
finalement dans une petite boîte
beaucoup de technologies pour avoir
quelque chose qui de manière autonome
nous renvoie des informations
d'observation de la terre d'accord alors
c'est tout petit en effet salade tiner
bis cube c'est ça c'est bien j'ai bien
compris c'est intégré à une une fusée
vous alors la fusée elle envoie elle
envoie beaucoup d'autres satellites 1
d'ailleurs il y aura à peu près une
cinquantaine de satellites du même type
que le nôtre alors soit plus petit soit
plus gros mais mais de la même catégorie
d'accord et pourquoi la californie
pourquoi c'est le lancement a lieu
depuis laquelle il fallait pour tous que
ça aurait pu être en guyane
oui oui alors en fait aujourd'hui ça
fait partie de l'évolution un peu du
spatial cirque aujourd'hui vous avez des
prestataires qui font l'intermédiaire et
qui en fonction des besoins que vous
avez d'orbité 2 et 2 jours de d'ethnie
han han justement dans l'espace vous
propose une agence ou une autre d'accord
alors quels sont les démissions et ce
quoi qui a deux missions essentielles
mais de ceux de ce nain de satellites
donc alors il a plusieurs fonctions
effectivement il en al s'apprend la
principale mission scientifique va être
de regarder le bilan radiatif de la
terre c'est à dire les missions du les
délais les radiations du soleil qui
arrivent et qui donc réchauffe note de
notre planète
et puis le le le l'énergie qui sort de
la planète dans l'infrarouge et donc on
va pouvoir créer le bilan de sa en
regardant et le flux infrarouge et plus
ultra violet qui vient du soleil
simultanément d'accord et
la vision elle durera combien de combien
de temps la mission de ce satellite
on espère le plus longtemps possible
c'est jamais sait jamais on ne sait
jamais et on espère déjà que ça va
fonctionner parce que il ya quand même
beaucoup d'aléatoire dans le spatial
comme on l'a vu récemment et donc on
aimerait bien typiquement un an ou
quelques années ça sera pas tellement
plus que ça à contenu voit la dimension
de ce2 de ce système
voilà on aimerait bien non ce serait
l'idéal
et quand on dit nadau c'est à dire que
dans un tout petit espace il ya des
milliers d'informations qui sont
contenues au fond jusqu'aux est-ce qu'on
peut expliquer effectivement pour les
pour les gens qui connaissent pas c'est
que typiquement aujourd'hui leur
smartphone est en fait un anneau
satellite vrai il ya exactement sur la
même chose il ya une caméra y'a un
système pour transmettre les
informations il ya un ordinateur de bord
bon sauf qu'un téléphone
si vous le mettez dans l'espace il va
tout de suite explosé on l'a bien vu
avec un tout petit peu de surpression
dans les avions les battre et qu'il a
fait et c'est donc voilà donc fait boxer
c'est quasiment un smartphone serait
mais mais mais robuste pour résister aux
conditions un petit peu extrême du
spatial
avec déjà plusieurs missions auxquelles
le latmos et et travail d'observation de
notamment de la planète
yahia la mission rouvert persévérance
notamment avec le d'associer avec la
nasa vous allez lancer ce que tu crois
aussi un drone vers titan c'est ça tout
à fait alors là on est bien placé pour
le voir on a on a ce rover sam curiosity
bris qui continuent de fonctionner et
qui amène beaucoup beaucoup
d'informations sur le sous sol est donc
peut-être
les conditions qui a pu y avoir
historiquement sur mars le rover
persévérance va pas venir prendre le
relais avec d'autres d'autres
fonctionnalités et donc ça c'est pour
mars
ça c'est bien évidemment tout ça c'est
des programmes qui dure des dizaines
d'années et japonais prend déjà du temps
alors il est correct en mars
il ya dix ans quelques années quand même
parce que finalement au tourne autour
d'autres planètes et cetera pour pour
finalement gagner en vitesse et on a
aussi de toute façon déjà au moins une
dizaine d'années de développement
donc c'est des programmes qui dure une
trentaine d'années typiquement et ses
danses akossi que les nanos sat sont
très intéressants alors au moins pour
l'observation de la terre c'est que le
nano set on a mis deux ans à le réaliser
ella ella et là on est plutôt sur 30 ans
donc voyez au niveau des carrières de
chercheurs c'est quand même pas la même
chose que d'attendre pendant trente ans
ces données ou les attentes pendant deux
ans et donc du coup après persévérance
on va avoir effectivement le même type
d'instrumentation qu'on a autour de mars
mais cette fois ci sur titan dans son
édition titan c'est l'une des une des
lunes 1 c'est ça voilà donc du coup mais
qu'à des caractéristiques qui sont très
intéressantes pour la terre primitive
on retrouve un peu des caractéristiques
qui avait peut-être dans la terre
primitivement donc on va essayer de
comprendre des processus qui appuient
avoir lieu justement il ya très
longtemps sur terre tu reviens petit peu
en arrière avant ce lancement vous en un
peu anxieux quand on a construit comme
ça on a nos satellites et qui va partir
dans quelques heures on est toujours
anxieux
pour pour les missions spatiales parce
qu'il ya toujours même même si on y met
et n'a prévu il ya toujours un a prévu
on le voit bien la mission de taranis ou
dans lequel nous aussi nous étions
impliqués
bon ben voilà allait elle est tombée à
l'eau c'est c'est toujours et on a eu
aussi une mission sur mars ou
l'atterrisseur ccra écrasé sur mars
donc on connaît ces imprévus on connaît
ces imprévus on est très anxieux et on a
encore plus anxieux quand finalement on
a été quasiment les seuls à développer
d'un bout à l'autre le système parce que
la seule responsable bien qu'il peut se
passer des choses qui seront pas notre
responsabilité et on croise les doigts
pour que tout se passe bien c'est assez
symbolique au fond ce lancement de
l'évolution de ce qu'on appelle la
conquête spatiale et les grands
événements avec l'homme qui va marcher
sur la lune enfin très spectaculaire qui
était aussi nié à la guerre froide un
combat autres c'était très patriotique
entre les états unis et l'urss
la chine s'y met aussi maintenant on a
l'impression quand même que aux foules
le but quand on revoit des satellites
dans l'espace est de mieux comprendre ce
qui se passe chez nous allez les deux la
connaissance est toujours lié c'est à
dire que finalement ce qu'on observe
ailleurs on peut le transposer chez nous
donc ça ça toujours un peu et ait eu
lieu
alors puisqu'il ya c'est que nous en
tant que scientifique on l'a vécu un
petit peu différemment même si on sait
bien que les mes problèmes de
géopolitique sont importants notre
laboratoire a travaillé a travaillé
pendant des dizaines d'années sur le
spatial et même pendant la guerre froide
avec les russes et avec les américains
et les français
on a eu des sciences qui valent à kitty
king des astronomes des cosmonautes
d'affaires et là encore on travaille
typiquement avec le cnes sur la mission
c'est faux sat qui mesurent la hauteur
des vagues
ça c'est une mission franco chinoises
oui je dirais que nous voilà on
travaille sur la science avec tous ceux
qui ont envie de travailler mais après
bien évidemment il ya les états qui ont
7 c'est un peu cette compétition
géopolitique il ya toujours cette
compétition un peu moins les finances la
lune sur la face cachée de la lune ils
sont en train de montrer leurs muscles
nécessaires c'est certain il ya un autre
phénomène qui est plus nouveau suis là
peut-être suivi ou la
privatisation de la conquête de l'espace
et évidemment parle beaucoup de muscles
qui a envie d'aller dans l'espace il ya
aussi des du tourisme spatial
ça c'est assez nouveau c'est nouveau et
je pense que c'est effectivement durable
et est maintenant pour nous c'est très
important pour un laboratoire comme nous
parce que ça va être ça va être le cadre
dans lequel falloir travailler
le nano sa tête une très bonne
illustration pour ça puisque finalement
nous avons nous mêmes règles et
récupérer les fonds alors certains
publics mais beaucoup aussi privé
typiquement on embarque un capteur
médical d'une société qu'il a développée
pour le tester dans l'espace puisque
l'idée c'est que ce capteur pourrait
servir les astronautes
donc il faut le valider spatiale mais du
coup là on a des fonds privés
donc on est en train d'être déjà notre
nanosatellites nano s'attaque un envoi
vias p 6
c'est déjà pu la filière habituelle et
donc on voit bien qu'on est on est on
est quand même dans une transformation
de la méthode et pour nous aussi
scientifique
on va devoir s'adapter a probablement
plus de 2 de collaboration public privé
dans le futur parce qu'aujourd'hui ce
qu'on s'aperçoit c'est que malgré tout
la recherche et des besoins économiques
souvent se rapproche il ya intérêt oui
des intérêts communs et puis ça coûte
quand même très cher des salles d'eau
fraîche et lorsqu'on observe la terre
qu'on observe pour des questions
opérationnelles de télécommunication ou
de ou de surveillance l'école observe
pour des questions du climat ou la météo
ou de la science finalement c'est les
mêmes outils donc il faut travailler
ensemble est-ce que les précautions
soient les mêmes parce que je me
souviens qu'une chercheuse du latmos
m'avait raconté qu'en musk envoyer des
choses hors espace conte sa revient dans
les procédures habituelles pour cette
public cette nettoyer évidemment les
capsules et des satellites pour ne pas
transporter par exemple de bactéries et
que priver le faisait peut-être moins
alors oui oui c'est sûr que quand le
privé rentrer il va falloir que que le
gendarme public
soit aussi vigilants il ya beaucoup
d'aspects de ce type là typiquement on
va avoir beaucoup plus de choses dans
l'espace
il va falloir aussi qu'elle soit assez
noir pour pas finalement polluer la
luminosité de l'espace et donc il ya
beaucoup de choses qu'il va falloir
réguler c'est très clair dès lors que
vous avez des privés ou d'augmenter les
noms de 2,2 de potentiels participants
il va falloir effectivement un
régulateur il falloir qu'il règle je
parle d'elon musk parce qu'il est très
connu mais il ya d'autres il ya beaucoup
d'autres privés qui qui qui sont
intéressés oui et du tourisme spatial
lancé ah oui alors tout à fait alors
nous nous on est juste en train de
discuter avec une petite entreprise qui
qui qui qui va prévoir dvd des vols
habités sur ballons par exemple alors
ces vols habités ils vont aussi servir
pareil d d d d d applications
commerciales et des applications un
scientifique
il est donc oui on va on va retrouver et
et même sur les sur les lanceurs on voit
que que des privés développent leur
propre lanceur à la manière des
lendemains
donc on a on a un foisonnement
foisonnement qui va être très riche mais
qui est plutôt une chance mais qui va
falloir organiser
il ya eu un moment des gens qui sait au
fond reste que ça sert pas à grand-chose
de dépenser de l'argent pour aller voir
ailleurs alors qu'il ya des problèmes
ici mais au fond c'est on s'aperçoit est
le levain de satellites en est la preuve
c'est que on apprend quand même beaucoup
sur nous en attendant l'espace beaucoup
sur la terre beaucoup sur la pollution
et d'ailleurs vous fait beaucoup de
recherches et là dessus alors c'est
aujourd'hui c'est totalement nécessaire
est effectivement
je pense que ce genre de remarque vient
du fait que les gens ne se rendent pas
compte combien ils sont dépendants du
spatial pour beaucoup beaucoup de choses
finalement et que si on arrêtait nos
satellites finalement d'un secours se
rendrait compte de notre dépendance au
spatial
donc en fait le spatial il n'y a pas de
problème il faut juste pouvoir le régler
correctement et donc falloir vivre avec
ça parce que c'est déjà bien bien bien
clairement ici et ça va l'être de plus
en plus avec les partenaires privés
parce qu'on voit bien que tout le monde
va avoir des besoins aussi qu'ils seront
pas forcément que des besoins
gouvernementaux a abaissé la preuve avec
ce lancement qui aura lieu donc dans la
nuit de mercredi à jeudi
cette nouvelle collaboration entre le
privé et public les chercheurs les
chercheurs comme vous et puis les filles
défilent merci c'est tout à fait voilà
un nouveau monde à bâtir autour du
spatial merci beaucoup vu quelqu'un
merci beaucoup à vous
il